[Applause]
hi drew hi jen how
are you i'm so good i'm so happy to be
here
you don't understand like how much i am
obsessed with you oh my gosh
well i want to be like up in your club
jen
i mean i'm like i you
really do you know whether it's like
you're on vacation with chrissy teigen
or doing bella hadid madonna
i mean katy perry haley bieber
you know everybody gwen stefani it's
unbelievable it's crazy i'm so so lucky
i work with so many incredible
incredible women
i pinch myself all the time it's
incredible
now you grew up actually in hawaii you
split your time right
yes i grew up in hawaii and in utah
before i came to l.a
so why have anything to do with the name
of your company
it does a bit yes i was really inspired
by
the french women that i would see during
paris fashion week on the streets with
just
really cool hair and effortless makeup
and just
they were the coolest and so when i
started thinking about a name
i was thinking about french names and we
went with way
it's the casual way of saying yes in
french
and i took off a letter so it looked a
little hawaiian but definitely our
scents are inspired by all the smells i
grew up around
i think it's just so amazing and you've
just done so much
with your life and cosmetology is one of
the many industries that's been so
affected by this pandemic
and uh jen and i heard about this
amazing salon
in minneapolis and they were giving away
free
hair care services to frontline workers
despite struggling themselves and
jen and i wanted to meet them there they
are bee and sadie
hi hi we're so excited to see you
um this is jen hi jen hi jen
so nice to meet you so nice to meet you
it's so great to meet you guys you're
amazing
um so your salon lost so much money
during quarantine
um but you still wanted to give out free
services
b why are you such a good person just
tell us
um our story started eight and a half
years ago
um we opened up our first salon
in st paul minnesota anyway it's been
very
successful all of the years that we've
been open um
and we took a leap about a year and a
half ago we were like let's do it let's
open our second location
um and we ended up signing our lease for
our second location in minneapolis
march 1st um and as you know the world
kind of
shut down a few weeks later um so it
certainly was not um the sort of
it wasn't the way that we thought it was
going to go no we were not
as busy busy as we wanted to be and so
we um we're trying to think of ways
to really lighten up the mood here
around this around the salon and to help
people in the community at the same time
so starting maybe in november or
december
we decided to offer free services to
healthcare responders
and anybody in the healthcare community
oh
i mean be it it must be so hard
sadie how much have you given out to
date
yeah um in december and january we gave
away
over 31 thousand dollars in services we
had so many
health care providers come in and say
you know i've been working
eight eight days straight i haven't
really done anything for myself in six
months
and so for them to be able to come in
and relax and kind of have a moment to
themselves
it was it was really great and our staff
our staff has really been amazing
they're so wonderful it's really been
it's been such a gift to be able to give
back to the community
in the way that we have and um you know
at this moment in time everybody just
needs to focus on taking care of each
other
well i commend you both so much for
everything you just shared with us jen
i mean you are the authority in all
things hair
you've run a salon you've really built
yourself up from having seen every
single aspect of the spectrum of what it
takes to
begin a business start you know at the
bottom is there anything
you know that you want to say to be in
sadie or that comes to mind
hearing their story yeah
i have to say guys like all of the
success and the glitz and glamour like
the moments in my
career that have stood out the most is
when i can be in service of other people
and
be in sadie your hearts and your spirit
are so inspiring to me
and i am so excited to tell you my
friends at dyson are going to give you
guys
twenty five thousand dollars worth of
tools
you've gotta be kids i swear you're
getting
the supersonic dryer you're getting the
dyson
corral straightener and you're getting
my favorite the air
purifier so you guys thank you so much
for all you've done
you're incredible for anyone who may be
watching at home the
dyson tools are just the most high-end
revolutionary best in technology supreme
expensive just top of the line thank you
thank you
so much i can't believe that i thank you
oh my god i'm so honestly i'm just so
inspired by your story and
what you've done to get back to your
community it's incredible thank you
oh thank you thank you that's really
amazing
well thank you to jen thank you sadie
and b
we will be in touch we'd love to be
checking in and seeing how things are
going
thank you thank you so much and thank
you so much
for coming on the show jen thank you
thanks for having me drew
thank you so much all right jen's new
book blowing my way
to the top is out now i highly suggest
getting a copy if you haven't already